Mit dem unternehmen neue linke hat in moskau eine krasse vision mast will
elektroden entwickeln die computer mit dem menschlichen gehirn vernetzen und darüber ein internet der menschlichen gehirne erzeugen wow
denn
Darin sieht er die einzige chance der menschheit eine
apokalypse durch künstliche intelligenz zu verhindern ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünschten bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts zu neuling
Wie sehen die pläne konkret aus und wie realistisch sind sie wirklich das alles und noch viel mehr in unseren willen mars chroniken
jetzt bei keksen science fiction herzlich willkommen
In der vergangenheit ist es verschiedenen forschungsbereichen gelungen das menschliche gehirn schritt für schritt
Zu entschlüsseln immer wieder ist das auch thema bei uns beispielsweise wenn es gelingt das
locked-in-patienten über eine computer sind schnittstelle sprechen können mit hilfe eines
Roboterarms blumen gießen können oder gitarre spielen mittlerweile sind es nicht nur mehr die kranken menschen die, im fokus
des interesses von eur und
computerwissenschaften stehen mittlerweile sind es auch gesunde menschen denn auch ihr gehirn kann durch technik optimiert werden
stichwort brain hecking in diesem bereich ist auch der unternehmer allen masc unterwegs und zwar mit seiner firma
Link dir im sommer 2016 mit acht weiteren personen gegründet hat das ziel
nervenzellen bereiche aktivieren und ihre signale
interpretieren und das in großem stil für die masse eben eine art
hirn cloud also in der die gehirne der menschen vernetzt werden alle gedanken wären dann für jeden der an diesen cloud
angeschlossen ist verfügbar aber von vorne im märz 2017
Hat machte das erste mal in der öffentlichkeit
Über die pläne von eurer link gesprochen demnach soll es nur noch wenige jahre dauern bis die entwickelte
technologie so weit ist dass sie bereits bei menschen mit schweren hirnschäden eingesetzt werden kann
patienten mit gedächtnisproblemen oder einem hirnschlag könnten so ihr gehirn wieder effektiver nutzen
Doch langfristig sind es nicht die kranken menschen auf die maske ist mit seinem unternehmen neuerer link abgesehen hat es soll vor allem eine
apokalypse der künstlichen intelligenz der ki
Vermieden werden vor der masse in der nahen zukunft fahrt erinnern immer wieder daran dass. Im laufe der evolution immer wieder mal die weniger intelligenten
spezis durch die
intelligenteren verdrängt worden sind nur wenn der mensch mit maschinen verschwitzt und dadurch dünner schneller und produktiver wird werden wir
mast vorstellungen zufolge nicht von der ki abgehängt in seinen vorstellungen können wir in einigen jahrzehnten elektronische
geräte direkt mit unserem gehirn verbinden und zwar mit hilfe implantierter chips
Im hirn die bits und bytes in gedanken über setzen können und umgekehrt und dafür hat musk eine menge hochkarätiger experten, am start
Angefangen bei sich selbst oft auch als der da vinci unserer zeit bezeichnet
und wohl unbestritten einer der besten ingenieure weltweit dazu kommt der ehemalige
chef chip designer von ibm und noch weitere erfolgreiche erfinder nicht zu vergessen auch einige der besten
Neurochirurgen weltweit natürlich ist das menschliche gehirn super komplex doch, im grunde
Funktioniert es ähnlich wie ein computer nämlich mit hilfe
von einsen und nullen also den binärcode eine eins steht für die aktion einer, nervenzelle
Die null steht für den ruhezustand doch der große unterschied zu computer
nervenzellen verändern sich permanent sie ordnen sich für kurze oder lange zeit an
So können wir uns immer mehr wissen einprägen es aber auch wieder vergessen oder verändern durch das so genannte machine learning kann auch ein
computer dazu lernt aber wenn er dinge einmal kann oder weiß gibt es keine möglichkeit dieses irgendwie abzustufen oder abzuschwächen
Diese lücke will maas mit neuling schließen doch wie genau soll das
Funktioniert was plänen sollen elektroden direkt ins menschliche gehirn transplantiert werden so entsteht eine computerhirn
schnittstelle so werden wir menschen in die lage versetzt direkt mit unserem bewusstsein in
computersysteme zu gehen lockers werden k s in solchem fall
unsere kollegen beziehungsweise nachbarn erhofft sich dass wir sie so verstehen und mit ihnen agieren
Erhofft sich dass wir uns so in unseren lebensraum mit der ki
Teilen können und sie uns nicht gefährlich wird falls dies alles funktioniert wird es die welt wie wir sie kennen komplett
Umkrempeln anstatt eine e mail
Zu tippen würde es ausreichen einfach kurz an den gewünschten inhalt
zu denken der computer
Verwandelt unsere gedanken dann in den entsprechenden text zudem hätten wir zugriff auf die gedanken und erfahrungen anderer menschen so könnten wir also
problemlos die erfahrungen von anderen erleben zum beispiel die eines promis oder eines soldaten
auch wenn wir bestimmtes fachwissen haben wollen müssen wir nur an diesen wunschdenken und
schon die gedanken entsprechende experten
herunterladen doch nicht nur die interaktion zwischen menschen und computern würde so komplett verändert werden sondern auch die kommunikation zwischen den menschen untereinander
Wenn die kommunikation verliefen nach machst läden dann direkt zwischen gehirn und gehirn ohne
datenverlust oder verzögerung weder unser mund noch unsere sprache werden dann mehr notwendig
Um komplexe inhalte an andere zu vermitteln also das würde dann auch die übersetzung in texte wiederum auf dauer
überflüssig machen auch viele missverständnisse
Sie durch das bloße hören von informationen entstehen eben oder das lesen von texten würden so von jetzt auf gleich
beseitigt klingt alles nach science-fiction pur
Doch auch wenn viele experten und expertinnen an der umsetzbarkeit dieser vision zweifel zeigen einzelne fälle was bereits heute
schon möglich ist nehmen wir beispielsweise
querschnittsgelähmte patienten und patientinnen die roboterarme nur mit hilfe ihrer gedanken steuern länger schon gibt es augen und ohren plantage die blinden und gehörlosen
das sehen beziehungsweise was hören ermöglicht doch ein riesiges problem bleibt die
speicherkapazität der computersysteme denn selbst supercomputer sind derzeit lediglich in der lage wenige sekunden der aktivitäten des menschlichen gehirns
aufzuzeichnen
Im frühling 2017 wurde bekannt dass neuling wohl einen antrag auf die genehmigung von tierversuchen
Gestellt hat ein offizielles statement gibt es dazu allerdings nicht bemerkenswert denn maske ist bei all seinen anderen
Aktivitäten durchaus aktiv bei twitter und so weiter unterwegs über neuerer link dagegen gibt es nur wenige postings und auch die
offizielle webseite ist mehr als spärlich
eventuell steckt da der gedanke dahinter
der in der tech industrie vor allem in diesem bereich weit verbreitet ist die dinge sollen sich nach maggi
anfühlen und nicht nach strenger wissenschaft und tierversuchen wie sie nun mal üblich sind auch mark zuckerberg von facebook beispielsweise
Hält sich bei seinen ambitionen ein gehirn machine interface zu schaffen
Er
Zurück ja wenn er als erstes neues zu diesem thema wie neuling und so weiter und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann hättet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
Täglich garantiert und zu vergrössern und gibt es ein kleines goodie das immer wieder für freude
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
genau vergessen wenn der glocke hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken ihnen macht warnt vor künstlicher intelligenz
Da geht es um die ich sag mal den auslöser die gründe für die gründung von eurer link ansonsten bis dann
bleibt